.
Ich wuchs
in einer total homophoben Welt auf.
Ich schämte mich unglaublich dafür,
dass ich bin, wie ich bin.
Ich schämte mich dafür,
"kein richtiger Mann" zu sein.
Dafür,
dass ich "kein richtiger Jugo" bin.
(Laut) Hast du ein Problem?
Du verdammte Schwuchtel!
- Stopp!
Okay, das geht vermutlich
noch etwas lauter. Alles gut.
Vor zwei Jahren
wurde ich verprügelt.
Als ich nach Hause ging,
kamen mir fünf Typen entgegen.
Stopp!
- Und noch mal so laut es geht.
- Sehr gut.
Ich bin lesbisch.
Ich bin eine Lesbe. Was auch immer.
Du bist eine Lesbe.
- Ja, ich stehe dazu.
Es gibt nichts, was ekliger ist.
Das war in mir drin, wahrscheinlich
von dieser verdammten Religion,
also vom Katholizismus her.
Es war der Abschaum
des Abschaums des Abschaums.
Ich will mit meinem Partner
durch den Vögelipark gehen
und mit ihm unter dem Baum
knutschen, wenn der Moment stimmt.
Du bist so gross.
Für mich ist der Glaube
ein essenzieller Teil meines Lebens.
Die Liebe zu Jesus
kann ich nicht aufgeben,
nur weil ich anders lebe,
als die Kirche es verlangt.
Ich werde
in diesem Brief aufgefordert,
innerhalb von vier Wochen anzugeben,
wer der Vater ist.
Es ist fast, als hätten wir
etwas Illegales getan.
So hat sich das angefühlt.
Ich glaube,
ich habe diese Diskriminierung
nie vorher so klar gespürt
wie in diesem Prozess.
Ich bin doch einfach ich selbst,
verdammt. Was soll ich sonst tun?
Ich habe es so satt, immer zu hören:
"Hast du ihn provoziert?
War das provokativ?"
"Bist du mit deinem Freund Hand in
Hand durch die Strassen gegangen?"
"Ist das provokativ?"
Nein, ist es bei den Heteros
ja auch nicht.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Sanftes Gitarrenspiel *
# He isn't wanted,
he isn't loved ...
Am Anfang fiel es mir megaschwer,
zu erzählen, was passiert war.
Es war megaschlimm für mich,
und ich fand auch nicht die Worte,
um zu beschreiben,
wie ich mich fühlte.
Ja. Ja.
(Englisch)
An dieser Stelle der Lyrics
versuchte ich, zu beschreiben,
wie ich mich
während des Überfalls gefühlt hatte.
# I can't move.
(Englisch)
# And I say it's a slow burn.
Ich konnte einfach nichts tun.
Ich wusste, dass ich schreien
oder mich wehren sollte,
aber ich konnte es nicht tun,
weil ich wie gelähmt war.
Ich hatte Riesenangst
und schäme mich auch dafür,
dass ich nicht mehr tun konnte -
um Hilfe rufen oder so.
Das ist auch ein Vorwurf,
den ich mir heute noch mache.
# When they come by me and
slip upon me while I can't move ...
Lenny Fluri
wurde vor knapp zwei Jahren
in der Bieler Altstadt von
fünf unbekannten Männern verprügelt.
Seither leidet er unter einer
posttraumatischen Belastungsstörung.
Unterstützung bekommt Lenny
von Psychiater und Therapeut
Rodolfo Borner.
Wie ist es für dich,
wieder in dieser Strasse zu sein?
Schwierig.
Schwierig und auch seltsam,
weil ich in letzter Zeit überhaupt
nicht mehr hier in der Gegend war.
Ja. Ja, ich vermeide es eigentlich.
Also den Ort des Überfalls
und die Umgebung.
Das ... Ja.
- Mhm.
Und dort vorne war es, nicht?
Geht's?
Es ist schwierig, aber ...
Ja. Ja.
- Mhm.
* Düstere, bedrückende Musik *
Wir waren vor einem Jahr schon hier.
Hier war es, nicht?
- Ja. Ich kam von dort hinten.
Ich war auf dem Weg nach Hause.
Und dann kamen mir von dort ...
* Räuspern *
... vier oder fünf Typen entgegen.
Sie nannten mich Schwuchtel und so.
Sie fragten,
ob ich ein Mann oder eine Frau sei.
Sie wollten mich nicht vorbeilassen.
Und dann packten sie mich.
Sie hielten mich fest.
Einer schlug mir
eine Flasche über den Kopf.
Und dann wurde ich ...
... ohmächtig.
Ich weiss nicht mehr viel.
* Gläsernes Klappern *
Und als du wieder zu dir kamst?
Ich lag noch hier.
Sie waren weg.
Seither
hat sich vieles verändert, nicht?
Ja, ich bin jetzt schwerhörig. Ich
habe davon einen Innenohrschaden.
Wahrscheinlich
vom Schlag auf den Kopf.
Der ist süss.
- Brauchst du die Lange schon?
Ja, die Lange kommt hierhin.
So?
- Ja. Willst du drehen? Soll ich?
Das ist gut so.
- Ja, super.
Ich habe eine anstrengende Aufgabe.
* Lachen *
Aha. Ich halte es fest.
Wir haben schon
einen starken Nestbautrieb, was?
Aber es ist megaschön.
Ein Kinderzimmer einzurichten
gibt auch viel zu tun -
v.a. bei zweien.
Nicole und Janina Zarotti-Zogg.
Seit zwölf Jahren sind
die beiden Psychologinnen ein Paar
und immer schon treibt sie
der Gedanke an eigene Kinder um.
Als ich mich outete und merkte,
dass ich Frauen liebe und
mit einer Frau zusammen sein will,
glaubte ich wirklich,
ich dürfe das nicht.
Ich dachte,
ich dürfe es dem Kind nicht antun.
Ich hörte immer wieder
von verschiedenen Personen,
das sei nicht natürlich.
Meine Vorstellung,
Kinder haben zu wollen,
war so klar, dass ich
am Anfang unserer Beziehung,
mit Anfang 20 sagte:
"Ich will unbedingt Kinder haben."
"Vielleicht muss ich halt mit
einem Mann ... Das ist einfacher."
In meinem Kopf
hatte ich durchaus das Konzept,
dass ich meine persönliche Erfüllung
zurückstellen würde,
um eine Familie haben zu können,
und auch, um den gesellschaftlichen
Normen zu genügen.
Wie mit einem Mann?
- Also ...
Niggi verlassen
und mit einem Mann zusammenkommen.
Das hast du mir
am Anfang wirklich gesagt:
"Jetzt ist das okay, und später ..."
"... opfere ich dich möglicherweise
sozusagen, oder ich gebe dich auf."
Ich würde meine eigene Erfüllung
in der Liebe opfern,
um ohne Probleme oder Schwierig-
keiten Kinder haben zu können.
Jetzt, da wir darüber reden,
finde ich das megakrass.
Ich auch. Es ist absurd, natürlich.
Aber es ist der Weg, den du und ich
auf andere Art zurückgelegt haben.
Man muss in sich selbst
Sicherheit gewinnen.
Sich vor sich selbst
und anderen zu outen ist das eine,
aber es hat Jahre gedauert,
bis wir zu unserer Identität stehen
und Stabilität und Sicherheit
gewinnen konnten.
Das ist ein riesiger Prozess.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Im Alltag erlebe ich es einfach so:
Wenn ich zu extrovertiert bin ...
... zu bunt, zu das,
also sozusagen zu schwul,
muss ich es mir öfter anhören.
Ich kann das also inzwischen
auch etwas steuern.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
An manchen Tagen geht's besser,
an anderen schlechter.
Je nachdem muss ich mir aber
bevor ich zur Arbeit gehe
auf dem Weg in die Bäckerei
schon anhören:
"Siehst du den? Das ist
jetzt eben diese Schwuchtel."
Da kann ich nur sagen: "Okay."
Du kannst ruhig mal dran ziehen.
So krass geil.
Das ist halt echt.
Also diesen Stil?
Das ist ein bisschen James Bond.
Ja.
Der 41-jährige Vincenzo D'Adamo
ist Frisör
in der Luzerner Innenstadt.
Hier kennt ihn jeder als Vinci,
den selbstbewussten und
stets gut gelaunten Paradiesvogel.
Aber Vinci wurde in seinem Leben
bereits fünfmal verprügelt,
weil er schwul ist.
Erlebst du das v.a. von Männern
oder gibt es diese Blicke
und Kommentare auch von Frauen?
In erster Linie schon von Männern,
aber es gibt auch
ganz witzige Teenie-Girls.
Kürzlich waren im Coop City
sechs Chicks ...
Darf man das überhaupt sagen?
Ich bin ja auch ein Chick.
... mit ihren Insta-Augenbrauen
und angeklebten Wimpern:
"Hey, das ist der Coiffeur,
der Schwule. Hey!"
Und ich so: "Hey, geht's noch?"
* Langsame Klaviermusik *
So. Ich habe ein Bild davon,
wie du fährst.
Sportivo.
Ich habe es auch
im Freundeskreis erlebt.
Z.B. lud mich jemand nicht
an seine Geburtstagsparty ein,
obwohl wir seit Jahren
befreundet waren.
Wenn er mit mir verkehrt hätte,
hätte man drauf kommen können,
dass er schwul ist.
Er ist hetero?
- Nein, er ist ...
Er ist schwul, aber nicht offiziell.
- Genau.
Da kann man jemanden wie dich
natürlich nicht einladen,
sonst wäre es offensichtlich.
Logisch.- Genau.
Ich stand auch schon am Bahnhof,
und zwei Gleise weiter rief jemand
"Schwuchtel" zu mir rüber.
Und da waren überall Leute.
Da ist es dir peinlich,
weil alle zu dir rüberschauen,
und zweitens ist man dann
einfach deprimiert.
Es ist nicht lange her,
da habe ich das beim Manor
in der Weggisgasse erlebt.
Da fanden sechs Teenager:
"Schau mal, die Schwuchtel!
Der ist sicher schwul."
Da hatte ich aber auch genug.
Ich ging zu ihnen hin und sagte:
"So, ihr hört mir jetzt mal zu!"
"Da ihr hier beleidigt und urteilt:"
"Ich bin überzeugt, dass
einer von euch homosexuell ist."
"Warum seid ihr Erwachsenen
gegenüber so respektlos?"
Das in der Weggisgasse.
Und es war laut.
Alle starrten hin
und zeigten mit dem Finger.
Da war eine Mutter mit einem Mädchen
und sagte:
"Schau, das ist ein Schwuler."
Und ich:
"Wollt ihr mich verarschen?"
Als ob die Elefanten des Circus Knie
unterwegs wären
und die Mütter
mit den Kindern hingingen:
"Schau, das sind die Elefanten
des Circus Knie."
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
(Janina) So?
- (Nicole) Nicht über den Ast.
So?
- Ja, so.
Das ist doch super.
Machen wir hier noch
eins nach unten?
Ich lasse dir das kurz hier.
- Ja.
Nachdem wir uns entschieden hatten,
zusammen Kinder zu haben,
hatte ich ursprünglich
die sehr klare Idee,
dass wir jemanden nehmen,
den wir kennen.
Jemanden, der uns bekannt ist.
Eben um dem Dilemma auszuweichen,
dass die Kinder
den Vater nicht kennen.
Und du wolltest das Gegenteil,
nicht?
Ich hatte total Angst davor.
Ich dachte immer, dass genau
diese Situation kommen würde:
Du bist schwanger,
du bist die leibliche,
vor dem Gesetz anerkannte Mutter,
und ich bin niemand -
also nicht für uns,
aber vor dem Gesetz.
Ich habe weder Pflichten
noch Rechte.
Ich hatte Angst, dass ein
uns bekannter leiblicher Vater,
seine Rechte vielleicht
wahrnehmen wollen würde.
Wir haben jahrelang,
wirklich mehrere Jahre lang
darüber gesprochen.
Am Ende haben sich unsere Rollen
fast umgedreht.
Ich dachte dann, ein anonymer
Samenspender wäre auch gut,
weil wir dann unsere eigene,
intakte Familie
ohne Einfluss von Dritten
sein würden.
Und Niggi fand plötzlich,
es wäre schön, wenn wir den
biologischen Vater kennen würden.
Schliesslich fiel die Wahl
auf eine anonyme Samenspende.
Und zwar in Wien.
Der ist megaschön.
- Ja.
Ausser eins.
Du hast so einen Instinkt.
Unglaublich.
Wien war magisch,
aber ein Riesenstress.
Ja.
- Ein Riesenstress.
Hier ist ein Foto von uns
am Flughafen - vor Wien.
Am frühen Morgen. Wann war das?
- Das war um 6 Uhr morgens.
Wir waren total aufgeregt.
- Mega, mega.
Wenn der Zeitpunkt im Zyklus genau
stimmt, muss alles schnell gehen.
Wir gingen hin, und die Nervosität
brachte uns fast um.
Das war kurz vor der Insemination.
Das war etwa 2 Min.
bevor unsere Kinder entstanden.
(Lachend) Genau.
Wir wussten nicht,
wie es ablaufen würde.
Es ist absurd,
dass wir ins Ausland gehen mussten.
Wir werden von einer
gynäkologischen Praxis betreut,
die selbst
Inseminationen durchführt.
Es ist so ...
Ich war dort und wusste,
dass die das durchführen.
Ich dachte einfach:
"Ich darf diese Dienstleistung
nicht in Anspruch nehmen."
Was ist das für eine seltsame Welt,
dass wir irgendwo hinfliegen müssen,
nur weil wir zwei Frauen sind,
während alle anderen sich einfach
hier behandeln lassen dürfen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Wow.
- Gewachsen, nicht?
Absolut. Ich würde sagen ...
... kaum wiederzuerkennen
seit letztem Mal.
Das habe ich auch gemerkt.
Immer mindestens eine Schwanger-
schaftskontrolle weiter als sonst.
Es liegen immer noch beide
gleich längs.
Liegen sie noch gleich?
Wunderbar.
Sehen Sie den Monitor gut?
- Ich sehe es super.
Welches ist der Kopf?
- Rechts, und links ist der Bauch.
Waren das Beine?
- Hier haben wir viele Extremitäten.
Die Füsse und daneben ...
- Das ist so herzig.
Kopf an Kopf. Brandheiss.
- (Frauen) Nein.
So herzig.
- Ist auf dem Bild ...
90° weg von hier ...
Ja, das geht gut.
Er kommt, er kommt.
Der kommt sogar super.
Jö! Er hält seine Hand so.
- Das ist der Junge.
Genau, perfekt.
Aber ... Oh mein Gott, jö!
Nein, also ... okay.
Niggi, wie herzig der ist!
- Ein Prachtskerl.
Diskussionslos.
Er ist so herzig.
* Verstärkter Herzschlag *
Das war der Junge.
Oh, da kommen ...
Das ist ein Fuss,
der gehört wahrscheinlich ...
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Für uns ist das grosse Thema,
dass wir wie
in zwei parallelen Welten leben.
Wir haben unsere eigene Welt
in unserem Umfeld,
mit unseren Familien,
hier zu Hause und bei der Arbeit,
in der wir total getragen werden.
Wir merken eigentlich nichts
von Diskriminierung oder davon,
dass wir anders sind.
- Hier sind wir auch zwei Mamis.
Es ist so klar, dass du ein Mami
bist und ich ein Mami bin
und wir uns
über unsere Kinder freuen.
Die andere Realität ist,
dass wir ...
Der Weg eines lesbischen Paars
zum Kinderhaben
ist unglaublich kräftezehrend,
es ist megateuer, es ist ...
Es gab viele Momente,
in denen wir Mühe hatten
oder sehr traurig
und verzweifelt waren.
Es ist eine Konfrontation.
Im Alltag vergessen wir,
dass wir nicht gleich sind.
Wir sind gleich, aber wir werden
nicht gleich behandelt.
Wenn dir bei der Geburt
etwas passiert
und du aus irgendeinem Grund ...
Wenn du z.B. nach dem Kaiserschnitt
nicht aufstehen kannst,
kann ich mich rein theoretisch
nicht um die Kinder kümmern.
Schlimmstenfalls
würden die Kinder weggenommen.
Wir haben versucht, uns abzusichern.
Wir sind
mit einer Anwältin in Kontakt.
Wir haben Unmengen an Dokumenten.
Darf ich in diesem Moment
meine Kinder betreuen?
Diese Entscheidung
liegt bei der KESB.
Das ist für uns ziemlich emotional.
* Leises Schluchzen *
Sorry.
- Wie Sie sehen.
Es ist so dumm,
weil es nicht unsere Realität ist.
Es ist nicht unsere Realität.
In der Realität ist alles gut.
Aber es lässt uns einfach ...
Es ... macht einen
auch irgendwie sehr hilflos.
Und es schafft Ängste,
die nicht existieren müssten.
Für mich war die grösste Veränderung
natürlich das Gehör.
Jetzt bin ich schwerhörig,
und vorher war ich das nicht.
Das ist auch, woran ich mich
am meisten gewöhnen musste.
Das war ziemlich schwierig,
gerade auch mit der Musik,
weil ich wieder Gitarre spielen
und singen lernen musste -
also wie es mit dem neuen Gehör
für mich klingt.
Neben der Musik besucht Lenny
eine Maturitätsschule in Bern.
Es ist das letzte Schuljahr
vor der Matura.
* Langsame Melodie *
Schon im Kindergarten
wurde ich gefragt,
ob ich ein Junge
oder ein Mädchen bin.
Ich wollte nicht antworten.
Ich gab einfach keine Antwort.
* Antreibende Melodie *
Ich wollte mich da schon
nicht einordnen und sagen:
"Ja, ich bin ein Mädchen",
oder: "Ja, ich bin ein Junge."
Das hat sich damals schon
falsch angefühlt.
Ich wusste auch nicht,
was ich antworten sollte.
Ich fragte mich da schon, ob ich ein
Mädchen oder ein Junge sein will,
ob ich ein Mädchen
oder ein Junge bin -
muss ich ein Mädchen
oder ein Junge sein
oder gibt es etwas dazwischen
oder daneben?
* Gefühlvolle Gitarrenmelodie *
* Dieselbe Melodie *
(Englisch)
# ... than he gets hugs.
Es gab Situationen in der Schule, in
denen ich mich ausgegrenzt fühlte.
Ich wurde auch
eine Weile lang gemobbt,
in der Oberstufe.
Das war auch
ziemlich schwierig für mich,
weil ich selbst
noch nicht ganz verstand,
wer ich bin, was das ist
oder wieso ich gemobbt wurde.
Ich hatte auch noch nicht
die Worte dafür
und traute mich nicht,
zu mir zu stehen.
# ... scared little boy
is still inside ...
Lenny identifiziert sich als nonbinär
und fühlt sich weder
eindeutig als Mann noch als Frau.
# ... slip upon him
while he can't move.
Okay.
Man weiss nicht,
wer die Täter waren.
Die Polizei hat sie nie gefunden.
Was würden sie wohl
denken oder sagen?
Ich weiss nicht.
Ich finde es schwierig,
das einzuschätzen.
Ich hoffe, dass sie merken würden,
dass solche Dinge
schlimme Folgen haben können -
psychische
oder dass jemand schwerhörig wird.
Ich hoffe auch,
dass sie es bereuen würden,
also dass sie merken würden,
dass megaschlimm war,
was sie getan haben.
Hoffentlich
würden sie das nicht mehr tun.
Was ist wohl mit ihnen passiert?
Wieso mussten sie zur Tat schreiten?
Vielleicht hat es damit zu tun, dass
sie mich nicht einordnen können.
Ich glaube,
gerade jüngere Jugendliche,
meist männliche Jugendliche
wollen vielleicht auch beweisen,
dass sie eben klar männlich sind.
Vielleicht wollten sie das
ihren Freunden beweisen
und wurden deswegen so gewalttätig.
Im Sinne von: "Wir sind nicht so."
Einfach diese klare Abgrenzung.
Sie sind halt männlich
und ich halt nicht.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Wenn ich abends
allein nach Hause gehe,
erinnert es mich schon sehr
an den Überfall,
weil ich Angst habe
und allein bin.
Ich weiss,
sie könnten mich auch verprügeln.
Die anderen haben auch einfach
mit einem Kommentar angefangen.
Ich wuchs
in einer total homophoben Welt auf.
Das Wort Homosexualität brachte ich
nur mit Negativem in Verbindung -
nicht mit Liebe,
nicht einmal mit Sex.
Nur mit reiner Negativität.
Ich sah irgendwann, dass es
Männer gab, die ich spannend fand,
die ich schön fand,
die ich irgendwie attraktiv fand.
Und da begriff ich wirklich:
"Okay, ich bin schwul."
Und als ich das begriff, wusste ich
sofort: "Das darf nicht sein."
"Ich kann mich
niemandem anvertrauen."
"Wenn ich das irgendjemandem sage,
bin ich erst recht allein."
Also war ich sehr stark
in einem Clinch mit mir selbst.
Einerseits wusste ich,
dass ich schwul bin,
andererseits wusste ich genauso,
dass es nicht sein durfte.
In diesem Widerspruch
verfing ich mich.
Als ich merkte, dass ich schwul bin,
begann ich, zu schauspielern.
Ich spielte die Rolle
des Hetero-Pascal.
Hetero-Pascal existiert nicht,
hat nie existiert
und wird nie existieren.
Trotzdem war das
der absolute Hauptanteil
eines Grossteils
meiner Kindheit und Jugend.
Er bestimmte mein Leben.
Ich war wie in einem Gefängnis,
in dem ich gleichzeitig
Insasse und Wärter war.
Ich war der allerschärfste
Beobachter meiner selbst.
Ich kontrollierte alles -
jede kleinste Kleinigkeit,
jedes Detail.
Ich kontrollierte, wie ich sprach,
in welcher Stimmhöhe ich
etwas sagte, wie laut ich sprach.
Ich kontrollierte, wie ich ging,
was ich anhatte,
wofür ich mich interessierte -
ob ich es wirklich
interessant fand oder nicht,
war völlig nebensächlich.
Das Hauptziel war,
die Rolle des Hetero-Pascal
so perfekt zu spielen,
dass niemand
hinter mein Geheimnis kommen konnte
und dass ich ihn
so überzeugend spielte,
dass ich so tun konnte, als ob es
den schwulen Pascal nicht gäbe.
Dann würde ich ihn ignorieren
und das Problem
aus der Welt schaffen können.
Ich hasste mich selbst abgrundtief.
Ich hasste, was ich war,
und ertrug es nicht, so zu sein.
Darum spielte ich diese Rolle.
Ich dachte auch: "Wenn ich mich
schon selbst nicht ertragen kann,
wie sollen mich andere ertragen?"
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Hello.
- Hallo, wie geht's?
Gut, und dir?
- Auch, danke sehr.
Endlich hast du's geschafft.
- Es war eine lange Fahrt von Bern.
Das glaube ich.
Darum bin ich in Zürich.
Pascal Pajic ist Medizinstudent
und lebt in Bern.
Schau, dort oben sind sie schon.
Wir kommen gleich rein.
Aufgewachsen ist er mit seinem
eineiigen Zwillingsbruder Patrick
in Chur, wo auch die Eltern
der beiden leben.
Mutter Svetlana ist bosnische Serbin,
der Vater, Smail,
ein Busfahrer in Chur,
stammt aus dem Kosovo.
Als sie erfuhren,
dass einer ihrer Söhne schwul ist,
kam das für beide überraschend.
Er sprang aus dem Schlafzimmer,
und ich dachte: "Was ist da los?"
Da sagte er:
"Mami, Papi, Pascal ist schwul."
Und ich dachte: "Okay."
"Ist ja nichts Besonderes."
Und er: "Was, schwul?"
Pascal kam in die Stube und sagte:
"Ja, ich bin schwul."
"Ich bin peder" - auf Serbisch.
Und dann ...
Er fing sofort an zu weinen.
Und ich dachte, vielleicht ...
Ich hatte schon geahnt,
dass er schwul sein könnte -
aber vielleicht auch nicht.
Irgendwo ...
- Ihr habt's schon gespürt.
Ich wünschte mir,
dass er es nicht ist.
Keine Frau, keine Kinder -
das sei schade.
Ich war überzeugt,
dass wir genau gleich sind.
Ich sah nichts.
Klar, im Nachhinein
sehe ich schon einige Anzeichen -
wir unterschieden uns ein wenig.
Aber in dem Moment hatte ich
nichts bemerkt. Wirklich nichts.
Welche Gedanken
habt ihr euch dann gemacht?
Mir wäre es lieber,
wenn er hetero wäre.
Heute immer noch?
- Ja.
Ich akzeptiere dich.
Wir stehen voll hinter dir.
Aber dass du wie Patrick
Kinder und eine Frau hast ...
Er kann immer noch Kinder haben.
- Ganz normal.
Sicher, klar.
Dass er mit einer Frau
statt einem Mann lebt.
Warum?
- Ich weiss nicht. Ist schöner.
Schöner?
- Ja.
Oder nicht? Was meinst du?
- Für mich nicht, nein.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Kaffee.
Und für Papa war's auch schwer?
Ja, eigentlich ...
Ich komme aus einem anderen Land.
- Ich komme aus demselben Land.
Ich meine, ich bin mit einer anderen
Kultur und Erziehung aufgewachsen.
Darum war es für mich ...
wie eine schlimme Krankheit.
Im ersten Moment denkt man:
"Wie kann ich ihn
vor der Krankheit beschützen?"
"Vielleicht
hat ihn jemand vergewaltigt."
Ich dachte: "Das Schwulsein
kommt nicht von der Natur her,
sondern von Gewalt. Und ich als
Vater konnte ihn nicht beschützen."
Darum kamen mir die Tränen.
Ich dachte:
"Was bin ich für ein Vater,
der sein Kind
nicht beschützen kann."
Ich kann mich noch erinnern,
wie ich sah, dass das Herz
meiner Mutter gebrochen war
und dass du so weintest.
Du konntest mich
nicht einmal anschauen.
Es war für mich sehr schwer ...
- Es tut mir leid.
... zu sehen, dass meine Eltern
meinetwegen so traurig sein können.
Ich war an dem Abend froh,
wieder nach Zürich gehen zu können.
Wirklich?
- Dass ich gehen konnte.
Für dich allein.
- Ja.
Dass ich die Situation
verlassen konnte.
Für die Eltern ist es schlimm genug,
aber wie viel schlimmer
ist es für den Jugendlichen?
Er hat zum Glück den Mut gefunden
und uns die Wahrheit gesagt.
Es gibt heute leider so viele,
die das verstecken.
Oder sich umbringen.
- Eben.
Da dachte ich ...
- Das ist traurig.
"Damit müssen wir aufhören."
"Wir müssen ihn unterstützen,
damit er keinen psychischen Schaden
bekommt und Selbstmord begeht."
Wir haben es ...
- ... verarbeitet.
Verarbeitet. Und jetzt haben wir
den Weg gefunden.
Wir appellieren an alle Eltern, dass
sie ihre Kinder verstehen sollen.
Das ist ...
- Miteinander reden.
Genau, und es ist keine Wahl,
sondern es ist normal.
Noch heute treffen die beiden Brüder
auf ihre Schulfreunde von damals -
junge Männer mit Migrations-
hintergrund, so wie sie selbst.
Ein Mann muss arbeiten, eine Familie
gründen und sie ernähren.
Fertig.
Als Hetero denkst du:
"Was heult diese Schwuchtel rum?"
* Lachen *
Grundsätzlich ist das so.
Ich kann auch so was Männliches
wie Feuer machen.
(Lachend) Feuer machen
und grillieren und Bier trinken.
Ich weiss gar nicht mehr, wie ich
gesagt habe, dass ich schwul bin.
Und ich weiss noch, dass du
dachtest, ich würde Witze machen.
Ja, das weiss ich auch noch.
"Der verarscht mich."
Und ich sagte: "Es stimmt wirklich."
"Wenn ihr nichts mit mir zu tun
haben wollt, verstehe ich das."
Dann sind wir aufgestanden.
- Ihr beide: "Ach was!"
"Hör auf,
so einen Blödsinn zu reden."
"Du bist immer noch unser Bruder."
(Patrick)
Dann kamen die lustigen Fragen.
"Aber wie machen das zwei Männer?"
Das war mehr er.
- Ihr alle. Ihr alle.
Am nächsten Tag ging einer vorbei:
"Findest du den schön?"
Bei jedem, der vorbeiging: "Stehst
du auf den? Was ist dein Typ?"
Aber ich hätte es
nie im Leben gedacht, ehrlich.
Wir kennen uns
seit der Primarschule.
Was hast du auf dich genommen,
um das so krank zu verstecken?
Wieso hast du dir das angetan?
Du warst immer mit uns draussen,
wir sind zusammen aufgewachsen.
Er wollte uns nicht verlieren.
Ich war selbst überzeugt, dass
Homosexualität etwas Negatives ist.
Ich habe das selbst gedacht,
mein ganzes Umfeld war so -
nicht nur ihr,
sondern auch meine Eltern,
aber auch in den Medien,
im Fernsehen und überall
wurde Homosexualität
als etwas Negatives dargestellt.
Ich war selbst davon überzeugt.
Mit zwölf wusste ich,
dass ich schwul bin
und dass das nicht sein durfte.
Ich wollte das nicht wahrhaben
und dachte: "Warum bin ich so?"
Ich wünschte jeden Tag,
endlich hetero sein zu können.
Ich weiss noch, als ich es
meinem Vater erzählt habe -
er kennt Patrick und Pascal ja auch.
Ich sagte:
"Papi, ich muss dir was erzählen."
Er ist eigentlich
bei allem echt locker drauf.
Ich sagte: "Pascal ist schwul."
Er so: "Im Ernst?"
Ich so: "Ja. Was denkst du?"
Er so: "Mein Sohn,
du kannst nicht alles haben."
"Er ist klug, er ist ein Supertyp -
dann ist er halt schwul."
Als ich mit meiner Mutter
zum ersten Mal darüber sprach,
dass Pascal schwul ist:
"Mama, Pascal ist schwul."
Und sie so: "Nein!"
Sie fand es nicht krass,
aber sie wurde traurig.
Sie dachte, das wäre eine Krankheit.
Sie so: "Ja, warum?"
Und ich so: "Weiss ich auch nicht."
Ich habe vor Kurzem,
vor einigen Monaten,
einem von dir erzählt ...
Ah, als wir bei Gamsat waren.
Ich sagte: "Ich war bei Gamsat,
und Pascal war auch da."
Und er so: "Ach, der Schwule?"
Ich so: "Ja."
Er so: "Ist er noch nicht
normal geworden?"
Ich so: "Mann, da wird man nicht
anders, der ist immer noch so."
V.a. die ältere Generation denkt,
das wäre eine Krankheit,
die irgendwann vorbeigeht.
Aber bei meiner Mama ist sogar
Vegetarismus eine Krankheit.
Ich versuche jedes Mal,
ihr das zu erklären:
"Du musst nur darüber nachdenken,
was du isst und warum."
* Bedrückende Gitarrenmusik *
Als ich neun Jahre alt war,
nannten mich meine Klassenkameraden
schon Schwuchtel.
Sie sagten:
"Du willst eh ein Mädchen sein."
Ich wusste aber,
dass ich das nicht will.
Für mich war eigentlich klar ...
... dass ich
im richtigen Körper bin.
Mit zwölf machte mich das so fertig,
daran kann ich mich erinnern,
dass ich in meinem Schlafzimmer
im vierten Stock
schon auf dem Fenstersims sass,
die Beine schon draussen,
und eigentlich springen wollte.
Wenn ich zurückdenke ...
... begreife ich es nicht.
Ich würde das nie wollen.
Es zeigte mir aber ...
... dass mich das gefühlsmässig
und sexuell sehr verwirrte.
Die äusseren Einflüsse,
die Beschimpfungen,
die abwertenden Wörter
wie Schwuchtel -
das kam da alles zusammen.
Das wurde nie ...
wirklich kommuniziert.
Meine Mutter
kam nicht zu mir und sagte:
"Ich habe mich gestern mit Papi
hingesetzt und es ihm gesagt."
Bei uns setzte man sich nicht hin
und sprach miteinander.
Ich kann mich erinnern,
dass ich mich extrem zurückzog.
Das war ...
Sorry.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Als ich mich mit 16 outete,
lebte ich mich dann wirklich aus.
Ich blühte richtig auf.
Ich wollte es am liebsten
jedem auf der Strasse sagen.
Es ging mir so gut.
Entsprechend ...
... provozierte ich es
natürlich unbewusst.
Ich merkte damals wohl schon,
dass es nicht einfach sein würde,
wenn man als Schwuler
so extrovertiert unterwegs ist -
bunt angezogen und alles.
Aber das liess ich mir nicht nehmen.
Für seinen extrovertierten Lebensstil
musste Vincenzo
einen hohen Preis zahlen.
Immer wieder.
Einmal wurde er nachts
von zwei Männern
quer durch
die Luzerner Innenstadt gejagt.
Das steckt ihm
heute noch in den Knochen.
Ich befand mich damals 30 ...
Also, ich befand mich damals
30 Min. lang
in einer lebensbedrohlichen
Situation.
Ich rief dreimal die Polizei an.
Beim ersten Mal
wurde ich ausgelacht,
weil ich sagte,
dass mich zwei Typen verfolgten,
die sagten,
sie wollten mich umbringen,
weil ich schwul bin.
Ich rannte hier im Quartier herum
und konnte mich
irgendwo in einem Innenhof
in einem Container verstecken.
Ich kam mir wirklich vor
wie ein junges Reh,
das von zwei Jägern gejagt wird.
Ich glaube,
ich bin noch nie in meinem Leben
so schnell gerannt
wie an jenem Abend.
Das ist für mich immer noch ...
... das Schlimmste,
was ich erlebt habe.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
# Here is my heart,
Lord, have it all.
Gell?
- Ja.
# My hands are open, I let go.
Ja, das ...
Das ist für mich speziell.
Es ist das erste Lied,
das sie selbst geschrieben
und rausgebracht haben,
bei dem ich nicht
auf der Bühne singen darf.
Jasmin musste die Bühne
nach ihrem Coming-out räumen,
denn in der Freikirche ICF gilt:
keine Queers im Rampenlicht.
Das war meine Leidenschaft.
Es war mein grösstes Hobby.
Es war meine Lieblingsbeschäftigung,
am Sonntag zweimal
auf der Bühne zu sein,
wenn ich nicht arbeiten musste.
Ich habe viel Zeit investiert.
Ich musste manchmal auch bei ihr zu
Hause für den nächsten Sonntag üben.
Es war ...
... das Grösste, was ich hatte,
was ich tun konnte
und was mir sehr guttat.
# ... the Holy One is Jesus.
Jasmin outete sich selbst,
obwohl sie genau wusste,
was auf sie zukommen würde.
# My future now unbreakable.
Eine lesbische Frau taugt in
den Augen von ICF nicht als Vorbild.
# ... I won't fade away.
# Jesus, come and have your way.
Es ist megaschade für mich,
aber ich musste es hinnehmen.
Es war entweder dieser Fratz hier
oder die Musik in der Kirche.
Es stand Herz gegen Leidenschaft,
und das Herz gewann.
Da war für mich klar,
dass ich das aufgeben müssen würde.
# So come what may,
I choose to stay ...
# ... in your love
that won't fade away.
Hier. Das war ganz früher.
Da habe ich noch gesungen.
Hier sieht man z.B., wie sie gerne
mit dem Licht gearbeitet
und konzertähnliche Strukturen
gemacht haben.
Es bedeutete mir megaviel,
dass ich meine grösste Leidenschaft
für Gott einsetzen konnte.
Ich hatte einen gewissen Stolz,
dass sie dort oben stehen und tun
konnte, was sie wirklich gerne tat.
Wir hatten auch
relativ viel Augenkontakt
und mussten ab und zu
sehr schmunzeln.
Es war eine schöne Zeit.
Es ist ein Dilemma.
Es ist kein schönes Gefühl,
dass man ...
... Dinge für etwas aufgeben muss,
was eigentlich längst
normal oder akzeptiert sein sollte.
Gerade auch in einer Kirche,
die nach aussen hin
immer sehr liberal wirkt
oder die durch die Musik
sehr liberal rüberkommt
und die Jungen anspricht und sagt,
sie sei modern und cool
und alle seien willkommen.
Und dann darf man trotzdem nicht
so sein, wie man will.
# In your love that won't fade away.
Irgendwann wollte ich auch einfach
ich selbst sein können.
Ich wollte zeigen,
wie glücklich ich dahinter noch bin.
In diesem Sinne
führte ich ein Doppelleben
mit zwei verschiedenen Gesichtern.
Das war eine Megabelastung für mich.
Und dann dachte ich: "Gut, dann
gibst du das Singen für das auf,
was dir viel mehr bedeutet."
"Für das, mit dem du vorwärtsgehen
willst, und für deine Message."
Wenn ich die Therapien gemacht
und versucht hätte,
mich auf Männer umzupolen ...
... hätte ich mich selbst verstellt
und nichts bewirken können.
Ich hätte
kein Statement setzen können.
Und ich hätte so
auch nicht versuchen können,
anderen Mut zu machen.
Dafür muss man selbst
einen ersten Schritt machen,
und den habe ich damit auch gemacht.
In meinem christlichen Umfeld
gab es sehr verschiedene Reaktionen.
Einige sagten von Anfang an,
dass sie Mühe damit hatten:
"Du bist ein Sünder
und musst eine Therapie machen."
Es gab aber auch solche, die sagten:
"Easy, megacool."
"Ich liebe dich immer noch,
denn Gott liebt dich ja auch."
Aber am Ende
lief es darauf hinaus,
dass ich all meine
christlichen Freunde verlor.
Auch diejenigen, die sagten,
sie hätten kein Problem damit,
wollten gar nichts mehr
von mir wissen.
Ich wurde geghostet,
wie man das heute so schön sagt.
So verlor ich
fast mein komplettes Umfeld.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Unser grösstes Glück.
- Ja, das kann man wirklich sagen.
Wir haben riesige Freude.
Du kannst ...
Wir können bald nach Hause gehen.
Morgen. Morgen gehen wir nach Hause.
- Ja.
Wir haben schon einige
Windeln gewechselt.
Ja, einige.
Und gestillt wie die Weltmeister.
Und Fläschchen gegeben. Wir haben
schon 50 oder 60 Flaschen gebraucht.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Zu Hause in Dübendorf legen
die Kleinen rasch an Gewicht zu.
Uns geht's megagut.
- Ja, wirklich sehr gut.
Es ist eine aussergewöhnliche Zeit.
- Ja, mega.
Jetzt sind wir einfach zu Hause -
ein halbes Jahr lang.
Das ist megaschön.
- Das ist es wirklich.
Das nimmt viel Stress raus.
- Es ist ein riesiges Privileg.
Ich wüsste nicht,
wie ich hätte arbeiten gehen können.
Ich wäre so traurig.
- Ja.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, wie du
das hier allein machen würdest.
Da bin ich auch nicht sicher.
Du allein zu Hause.
Rein vom Gesetz her
habe ich keinen Anspruch
auf Elternzeit
oder Mutterschaftsurlaub.
Der eine Vaterschaftstag,
den wir vom Betrieb her hätten,
fällt mir nicht zu,
weil ich Stand heute
noch nicht
mit unseren Kindern verwandt bin.
Rechtlich
existiere ich immer noch nicht.
Wenn wir in unserem Alltag sind,
wie jetzt, ist es ja klar.
Ich bin das Mami dieser Kinder,
Janina ist die Mama der Kinder.
Wir sind eine Familie.
* Jammern *
Eine laute Familie.
Oh, du Jammerer.
Ja.
Aber wir werden immer wieder
mit gewissen Dingen konfrontiert.
Wenn man die Geburtsurkunde
in der Hand hat und sieht,
dass da unsere Kinder stehen,
du stehst da - und ich nicht.
Ich bin einfach nicht da.
Das ist schon nicht ganz einfach.
Erst ein Jahr nach der Geburt
kann Nicole Zarotti-Zogg
eine Stiefkindadoption beantragen.
Die Windel ist aber schon voll,
was, kleiner Monsieur?
Bis dann ist Janina vor dem Gesetz
alleinerziehende Mutter,
eingetragene Partnerschaft
hin oder her.
Willst du ihm die Socken anziehen?
Ich habe nicht dieselben Rechte,
ich werde nicht anerkannt -
dass ich hier drin
nicht als Mutter anerkannt werde,
trifft mich sehr tief,
obwohl das nur der Staat ist.
Das Schlimme ist auch,
dass ich sagen könnte: "Ich gehe."
Jetzt. Heute.
"Ich habe mir das
anders vorgestellt -
ich hätte lieber wieder
meine 8 Std. Schlaf."
"Ich gehe jetzt.
Tschüss, Janina und Kinder."
Du wärst nicht abgesichert.
Und die Kinder auch nicht.
Das ist irgendwie absurd.
- Ja.
Die "Tagesschau" an einem Freudentag
für gleichgeschlechtliche Paare.
Die Schweiz
ist eins der wenigen Länder Europas,
die die gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe
nicht erlauben.
Die Schweiz ist
absolut hinterwäldlerisch, sorry.
... stimmte am Morgen deutlich
der Ehe für alle zu.
Überraschend deutlich sprach sich
die grosse Kammer auch dafür aus,
dass lesbische Ehepaare
Zugang zu Samenspenden erhalten.
(Mann) Grundsätzlich dagegen
war die Mehrheit der SVP.
Hier kommen wir
zum wahren Kern der Vorlage,
die diabolischen Charakter hat:
Letztlich geht es darum, einer Frau
das Vatersein zu ermöglichen.
Was?
Familien mit zwei Müttern
existieren,
sie sind inmitten unserer
Gesellschaft, sie sind gleichwertig
und ihre Kinder
sollen die gleichen Rechte haben.
Krass, das zu sehen, wo wir doch
eine solche Familie sind.
Die debattieren über unsere Rechte.
- Mega.
Das ist so absurd.
Schau, wie viele.
(Mann) Mit 124:72 Stimmen
stimmt der Nationalrat
Samenspenden für lesbische Paare zu.
* Jubel *
Das ist toll.
Ich hätte das nie gedacht.
Ich auch nicht.- Ich bin froh,
dass es so deutlich ist.
Wir stossen auf jeden Fall darauf
an, aber ich bin noch zurückhaltend.
Mal sehen, wie's weitergeht.
Das wird im Ständerat
eine grosse Diskussion geben.
Dort ist es gar nicht klar.
Sollte es vors Volk kommen,
wäre ich wieder zuversichtlich.
In der Gesellschaft
ist viel passiert.
Ob es zur Abstimmung kommt,
ist zurzeit noch offen.
* Gefühlvolle Klaviermusik *
Der Ständerat hat der Vorlage
ebenfalls zugestimmt,
darauf haben die Gegner/-innen
das Referendum ergriffen.
(Janina) Für mich ist vieles mit
den Ängsten der Menschen verknüpft.
Angst vor Veränderungen
bei konservativen Familien
oder Wertvorstellungen.
Die Verletzung,
die dadurch entsteht, ist so roh -
wer mischt sich darin ein,
wie man sein Leben plant,
wer man ist, wen man liebt und mit
wem man eine Familie gründen will?
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Das. Das ist es. So.
Setz dich hierhin, Liva.
- Ah, ja, entschuldige.
Die Historikerin und ihre Quelle,
Liva Tresch.
Ich hatte das kistenweise unten.
Corinne Rufli sammelt Erzählungen
von älteren lesbischen Frauen.
So.
Meine ganze Vergangenheit.
Da, die Kleine.
Das war in der 3. oder 4. Klasse -
mit diesem verdammten Haarband.
Wie ich es hasste!
Das ist Richligen.
So hat das ausgesehen -
ein ganz verblasstes Foto.
Aber noch
der schöne, alte Urner Stall.
Das sind meine Pflegemutter und ich.
Das ist das Haus
an der Axenstrasse in Flüelen.
Wann bist du nach Zürich gekommen?
- Anfang 1954.
Mit 21?
- Mit 20.
20?
- Ja.
Sie sagten: "So, Treschine, wir
zeigen dir, wo die Schwulen sind."
Wir betraten eine dunkle Kneipe,
und dort waren viele junge Männer.
Sie hielten einander
den Stuhl hin und so -
das imponierte mir wahnsinnig.
Unten in einer Ecke
sass dieses Mädchen.
Sie sah wie ein Junge aus.
Ich fand sie doch sehr schön.
Und sie sagten:
"Das ist eben eine Schwule."
Und ich sagte:
"Ihr seid doch Deppen."
"Das stimmt doch nicht -
eine Schwule."
Ich hatte kein Bild davon,
was eine Schwule macht oder ist.
Das war einfach
ein Nichts in der Landschaft.
Ja, diese Frau
ging mir nicht mehr aus dem Kopf.
Im Januar oder Februar
kam Sie mir ...
Sie bog um die Ecke, beim Select.
Da sprach ich sie an.
Wie seid ihr einander nähergekommen?
Es regnete,
als wir nach Hause gingen.
Ich musste zum Bleicherweg,
und sie hatte in der Nähe
des Kreuzplatzes ein Zimmer.
Und sie sagte:
"Schlaf doch bei mir."
Ich war elektrisch -
ich wusste nicht, was das war.
Sie trat splitterfasernackt aus dem
Bad - wunderschön, wie eine Königin.
Sie warf sich auch in Pose.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung, was das war.
Sie legte sich,
schön wie sie war, neben mich.
Meine Hände
machten sich selbstständig.
Sie war einfach schön.
Sie wandte sich nicht ab oder so.
Ich war einfach verzaubert. Ich
weiss nicht mehr, was passiert ist.
Jedenfalls
konnte ich sie befriedigen -
das klingt wüst, aber so war es.
Ich wollte dem da oben dafür,
dass er mir eine so schöne Frau,
etwas wahnsinnig ...
Es war nicht auf Frau gemünzt,
sondern er hatte mir etwas
so unglaublich Schönes gegeben.
Dafür wollte ich ihm danken,
und ich betete ein Vaterunser.
Stell dir das mal vor -
ein Vaterunser.
Und am Morgen
drehte sie sich zu mir um.
Sie sah mich an - sie hatte
wunderschöne, braune Augen.
"Ich hatte doch recht,
du bist doch schwul."
Das war wie ein Selbstmord.
Das war unglaublich.
Ich stieg aus dem Bett ...
... zog mich an,
ging zum Kreuzplatz,
und irrte einfach umher.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie lange das so ging.
Ich hatte eine solche Wut auf Gott.
"Unehelich, dumm
und jetzt auch noch schwul."
"Du verfluchter Schweinehund,
dir zeige ich,
was ich bin und was ich kann."
"Wenn ich schon des Teufels bin,
werde ich es dir zeigen."
Erst wollte ich nach Sisikon gehen.
Es gab einen Ort an der Axenstrasse,
von dem ich wusste,
wenn ich mich dort umbringen würde,
würde ich damit niemanden belasten.
Es war mein Ort für den Sprung.
Da war ich schon
in meiner Jugend oft gewesen.
* Wehmütige Musik *
Ich war mein eigener grösster Feind.
Aber der See war immer so schön.
Er kräuselte sich ...
Und dann der Gitschen.
Dort wollte ich hin,
aber ich hatte kein Geld.
Ui, sieh dir mal den See an,
wie er sich schön kräuselt.
So schmust das Wasser.
Ich liebe das.
In den 60er- und 70er-Jahren
dokumentierte Liva Tresch
das Leben in den
schwul-lesbischen Klubs Zürichs.
Heute sind ihre Bilder
im Sozialarchiv.
Eines Tages kam ein Anruf.
Sie sagte, sie habe
einen interessanten Bestand für uns.
Also von Liva selbst?
- Genau.
Hier haben wir z.B.
eine Schachtel mit Papierabzügen.
Der Bestand ist riesig - sie hat
etwa 6'000 Aufnahmen gemacht.
Hier wurden
einmalige Zeugnisse geschaffen,
die man in der Lesben-
oder Schwulenforschung
sonst gar nicht kennt.
Es ist unglaublich,
so einen Einblick zu haben,
denn das gibt es sonst nicht.
Man sieht selten in eine Welt,
die oft klandestin gewesen ist.
Klassische Archive archivierten
keine Geschichten lesbischer Frauen,
weil sie nicht den Wert hatten,
um archiviert zu werden.
Das ist natürlich ein sehr trauriger
Teil unserer Geschichte.
Jesses! Jetzt das Bein ...
Und der Stock klappt schon ein.
- Oh nein. Hält er nicht?
Ja, ja. Und hier ...
Wo bist du aufgewachsen?
- Hier stand unser Haus.
Als uneheliches Kind
wuchs Liva Tresch
bei Pflegeeltern in Flüelen auf -
eine Kindheit als Aussenseiterin.
Ich wäre absolut ein Junge gewesen,
aber der liebe Gott ...
Ausgerechnet, als Bruder Klaus
heiliggesprochen wurde.
Ich betete zu Bruder Klaus, denn
dann sollte ein Wunder geschehen.
Was hast du dir gewünscht?
- Ein Junge zu werden.
Dass irgendwo noch ein Schwänzchen
verborgen wäre, das dann ...
"Entweder kommt das jetzt raus,
oder ich bekomme die Mens."
Ich kam von der Kirche nach Hause,
und es blutete.
Ich ging ins Schlafzimmer,
legte mich ins Bett
und weinte und weinte und weinte.
Das Bluten
wäre mir noch egal gewesen,
aber da war definitiv klar,
dass ich ein Mädchen bin.
Zum ersten Mal seit Jahren fährt
Liva Tresch in die Gurtneller Berge.
Es werden Erinnerungen
an schwere Momente wach.
Wenn ich nur
etwas besser rennen könnte.
Hör mal!
- Ui, entschuldige.
* Plätschern *
Das Wasser.
Ja, hier war ich oft und greinte.
Weintest du?
- Ja.
Manchmal war es wirklich
verdammt schwer.
* Kuhglocken *
Wie schön dieses Klingeln ist,
und die Sonne scheint.
Schaut euch mal diese Wiese an -
wie sie schmusen und schmeicheln.
Man muss gleich drüberfahren.
Die sind wie Körper.
Wunderschön.
Ich habe die Frauen schon immer ...
Das fing schon an, als ich
den Mädchen die Schultasche trug,
nur wusste ich das nicht.
Die anderen wussten es längst und
sagten immer, ich sei schwul.
Ich dachte nie darüber nach,
was das ist.
Es interessierte mich auch nicht.
Dass das von hier aus ...
Ob die Liebe zu den Frauen
von hier aus kommt ...
Das ist wie dieser Stein, der mit
dieser Bewegung so wunderbar ist.
Das macht hier Freude.
Das interessierte mich
nicht da unten und nicht da oben,
es war einfach bei allem dasselbe.
Warum findest du Lesben
weniger schlimm als Schwule?
Auch wenn sie nicht lesbisch sind,
gehen Frauen
händchenhaltend durch die Stadt,
sie umarmen sich,
sie sind einander allgemein näher.
Also ist Nähe zwischen Frauen
akzeptierter als zwischen Männern?
Ja, weil es öfter vorkommt.
- Warum?
Wir sind damit aufgewachsen,
haben uns daran gewöhnt,
haben das mehr gesehen.
- Bei Frauen ist es halt anders.
Man stellt sich vor ...
(Gamsat)
... dass man mitmachen darf?
Nein, es ist eher ...
Man betrachtet es anders.
Man verkauft es anders.
- Oder so.
Wenn zwei Frauen
miteinander rummachen,
sind es immer noch zwei Frauen.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
- Ja.
Wenn zwei Männer miteinander
rummachen, ist es immer beklemmend.
Hello!
- Hoi, Simon.
* Stimmengewirr *
Schön, euch zu sehen.
Lang ist's her.
Schön, gratuliere.
Werden lesbische Frauen
eher positiv wahrgenommen?
Ja, so scheint es mir.
Schwule Männer
bekommen einen Stempel aufgedrückt
und erleben mehr Aggression.
Und wir lesbischen Frauen ...
Wir leben gesamthaft mehr Nähe und
sind in einem geschützten Rahmen.
Und dann der sexuelle Aspekt,
der manchmal ...
Ich finde das schwierig zu sagen,
aber in der Pornoindustrie
wird er mehr gepusht.
Oft sagt man: "Zwei Frauen, das wäre
doch nett, das finde ich heiss."
(Nicole)
"So geil, darf ich mitmachen?"
Genau, das.
Da denkt man: "Was läuft mit dir?"
"Hast du nicht verstanden, dass zwei
Frauen keinen Dritten brauchen?"
Man würde bei einem Heteropärchen ja
nie fragen, ob man mitmachen darf.
Das ist total übergriffig.
- Ja, total.
Da wird die Beziehung
nicht richtig anerkannt.
Ja, genau. Wir werden oft
nicht ganz ernst genommen.
Entweder machen wir es
nur für die Männer,
oder es ist einfach
keine echte Beziehung.
Nicht gleichwertig.
- Ja, genau.
Wenn nur der richtige Mann käme,
wären wir dann heterosexuell.
Das ist es.
"Ihr braucht einfach einen Mann.
Euch fehlt ..."
"Du hast
schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht."
Meine schlimmste Erfahrung ist,
dass ich gefragt wurde,
ob ich sexuell missbraucht
worden sei, um so zu werden.
Ach, direkt so?
- Ja, das hat mich schockiert.
Solltest du darauf antworten?
Krass, das fragt man doch nicht.
(Eva) Das finde ich sowieso schräg:
"Erzähl mal vom Lesbischsein."
Und die Frage nach dem Sex ...
Wenn sie mich nicht kennen
und dann erfahren ...
... dass du eine Lesbe bist.
- "Ah, du bist lesbisch?"
Und dann kommt:
"Ja, darf ich denn fragen?"
Dann sagst du:
"Was willst du fragen?"
"Wie ist denn der Sex bei euch?"
Und: "Fehlt denn nicht etwas?"
"Habt ihr denn auch Sexspielzeug?"
Wenn man
eine homosexuelle Person trifft,
warum erlaubt man sich,
generell über Sex zu reden?
Manche wollen ja zurückhaltender
mit dem Thema umgehen,
andere sind offener - ob lesbisch,
schwul, hetero oder was auch immer.
(Nicole) Das erleben wir
jetzt auch als Familie.
Wir werden
auf der Strasse angesprochen -
gerade mit den süssen Zwillingen -
und man stellt uns intime Fragen.
"Wie habt ihr das gemacht?
Wer ist wirklich die Mutter?"
Unsere Antwort ist immer:
"Wir sind beide die Mütter."
Und dann kommt megaoft die Frage:
"Aber wer hat sie ausgetragen?"
Das ist nicht relevant.
Wir sind beide die Eltern.
"Aber ich will jetzt wissen,
wer sie ausgetragen hat."
So fordernd? Spannend.
- Ja. Ja.
Bei gewissen Dingen
verstehen mich Menschen,
die nicht homosexuell sind,
einfach nicht so gut wie ihr.
Das ist einfach so.
Wir teilen etwas miteinander.
Ich finde es schön,
dass wir eine Community haben
und füreinander einstehen.
Wir müssen ja für unsere Rechte
kämpfen - das tun wir auch bewusst.
Wir haben eine Community,
aber es ist wichtig,
dass wir uns nicht
von der Gesellschaft abgrenzen.
Es ist megawichtig, dass wir uns da
nicht selbst im Weg stehen
und uns zu Sonderlingen machen.
Wir wollen Gleichberechtigung,
wir wollen gleich sein.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Es gibt Menschen,
die Wut ausdrücken,
auf den Tisch hauen,
laut schreien oder sich
bei den Tätern direkt revanchieren.
Hattest du mal eine Wut
auf die Täter
oder hattest du solche Gedanken?
Wenn ich die Chance gehabt hätte,
hätte ich sie nicht ...
Ich würde sie jetzt nicht mehr ...
Ich will sie nicht schlagen.
Aber es gab schon Zeiten,
da wünschte ich mir,
sie wüssten, wie sich das anfühlt,
oder dass ihnen vielleicht sogar
dasselbe passieren würde.
Aber meistens war das nur ein kurzer
Gedanke, und ich bereute es danach.
Ich wünsche das
eigentlich niemandem.
Ja.
Doch, doch.
Und dann hatten sie voll Angst.
Oft hört man ja das Vorurteil,
dass junge Männer
mit Migrationshintergrund
homofeindlicher sind
als alle anderen.
Wieso ist das so, was meint ihr?
- Das fängt schon bei der Dings an.
Dem Dazugehören zu einer Gruppe.
Dort beginnt die ganze Thematik:
"Ich will da oder dort dazugehören."
Und wenn bei fünf Personen
einer das Alphatier ist und sagt:
"Das ist nicht gut",
dann gehen die anderen alle mit.
Wenn man als Migrant
einmal Anschluss gefunden hat,
hat man Angst, diesen Anschluss
wieder zu verlieren.
Du hältst dich daran fest
und machst vieles mit,
auch wenn du das
nicht unbedingt willst.
Als Schweizer ist es einfacher,
wieder Anschluss zu finden.
Bei solchen Leuten
muss man etwas tiefer schauen.
Nur weil einer
einen anderen schlägt,
weil der schwächer ist oder so,
heisst das nicht,
dass er ein schlechter Mensch ist.
Vielleicht ist ...
- Vielleicht ist er schlimmer dran.
Er wird in der Schule
oder der Gesellschaft fertiggemacht.
Und jetzt kann er sich beweisen,
dass er stärker ist.
Er sucht einen Schwächeren ...
- Das ist vielleicht ein Moment,
in dem er sich gut fühlt. Er kann
etwas besser als der am Boden.
Ich glaube, Schweizer
sind genauso homofeindlich.
Die Homofeindlichkeit
ist überall vertreten -
in jeder Gesellschaftsschicht,
in jedem Volk genau gleich.
Ich glaube aber, dass Schweizer
das z.B. nicht so herausposaunen.
Sie machen das in ihren Kreisen.
Es ist unsere Art, uns zu äussern.
Wir haben keine Mühe damit,
zu sagen, was wir denken.
Das ist im Schweizer Bild ...
(Patrick)
Das ist vielleicht sogar schlimmer.
Sie denken genauso schlecht,
aber im Stillen, im Geheimen.
So können sie immer sagen: "Die
Moslems, die Ausländer sagen das."
So können sie ihren Hass durch den
Ausländer und den Moslem ausdrücken.
So stehen sie im besseren Licht da,
und wir sind vorn an der Front.
Ich sage immer, dass das keine Frage
der Nationalität ist,
sondern vielmehr
der sozialen Klasse.
Wenn jemand in einer
tiefen sozialen Schicht ist,
nicht so viel Geld, dafür
Probleme bis zum Abwinken hat -
gleichzeitig hat er vielleicht
einen Migrationshintergrund,
d.h., er fühlt sich
weder hier noch dort zu Hause
und steht
zwischen Stuhl und Bank ...
Er hat keine soziale Perspektive.
Vielleicht hat er rassistische
Ausgrenzungserfahrungen -
sein rassistischer Lehrer
sagt ihm jeden Tag:
"Du bist ein dummer Jugo
und landest nur auf der Baustelle."
Irgendwann hat dieser Mensch
soziale Bedürfnisse.
Er will irgendwo dazugehören,
will wichtig sein, geliebt werden.
Aber er hat nie so viele soziale
Perspektiven wie ein Schweizer Kind.
D.h., er klammert sich irgendwann an
das, was er hat: seine Männlichkeit.
Er denkt:
"Ich bin ein starker Mann."
"Das habe ich. Ich bin ein Mann
und kann auf andere herabschauen."
Und wenn dann irgendwer kommt,
der feminin ist und sein ganzes Bild
der Männlichkeit infrage stellt ...
(Patrick) Dass er sie noch hat.
... was ist dann seine Reaktion?
Er wird aggressiv
und will zuschlagen.
Es ist alles, was er noch hat.
Und wenn er das verliert,
ist er in seinen eigenen Augen
nichts mehr wert.
Wenn wir als Gesellschaft
weniger rassistisch sein könnten,
wenn wir weniger dieses
Männer- und Frauenbild hätten,
wenn viele Dinge "normal" wären,
könnten wir diesen Menschen
eine soziale Perspektive bieten
und hätten viel weniger Probleme
mit Homofeindlichkeit.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Ich trainiere seit mehr als
20 Jahren Selbstverteidigung.
Du sollst lernen, wie du solche
Situationen vermeiden kannst.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich müsste
kräftiger oder flinker werden.
Ich würde mir wünschen,
dass du künftig,
wenn dich jemand beleidigt,
einfach für dich sagen könntest:
"Das ist ein Idiot.
Das hat nichts mit mir zu tun."
Die Bedrohung kommt auf dich zu.
Du sagst: "Stopp, bleib stehen.
Komm nicht näher."
Dann entfernst du dich
aus der Situation.
Nicht hier warten. Das sind ein
dummer Ort und ein dummer Mensch.
Du hast hier nichts verloren.
Was grinst du so, Scheissschwuchtel?
- Stopp! Lass mich in Ruhe!
Wie redest du mit mir?
Verpiss dich! Wichser.
Genau.
Wenn du davonrennen kannst, geh.
Ich will ihn emotional treffen.
Die Idioten, denen du begegnet bist,
wollen dich emotional treffen.
Hey, Wichser,
was bist du für eine schwule Sau?
Was stimmt mit dir nicht?
- Stopp!
Verpiss dich, Hurensohn!
- Lass mich in Ruhe!
Wichser, hau ab!
- Ich will nichts von dir wissen!
Wenn ich zurückdenke,
war die Verfolgung schlimmer
als die Schläge und Fäuste,
die ich kassiert habe.
Von solchen Dingen
habe ich Albträume -
dass doch einer plötzlich
ein Messer aus der Bauchtasche holt
und mich
in irgendeinem Innenhof absticht.
Dass ich dort verblute.
Manchmal bin ich klatschnass
und schweissgebadet,
habe Angstzustände und zittere.
Da merke ich,
dass das echt heftig war.
Es gibt leider Situationen, in denen
du selbst Gewalt ausüben musst.
Genau so, Vinci.
Reden, dann schlagen.
- Hau ab!
Lass mich in Ruhe! Hau ab!
Hau ab und lass mich in Ruhe!
Hau ab!
Geh mir aus dem Weg!
- Lass mich raus!
Auf dieser Höhe.
- Noch höher?
So.
Sam und Jasmin wuchsen beide
in religiösen Familien auf.
Das ist der Einsegnungsvers,
den ich damals bekommen habe.
"Er hat seinen Engeln befohlen,
dass sie dich behüten
auf allen deinen Wegen,
dass sie dich auf Händen tragen
und du deinen Fuss
nicht an einen Stein stossest."
Psalm 91, 11-12.
Wurdest du behütet?
J... Ja. Ja.
Es hätte ...
Im Hinblick auf das Outing
hätte es für mich ...
In meinem Inneren hätte es
viel schlimmer ausgehen können.
Ich hätte komplett
daran kaputtgehen können -
das ist zum Glück nicht passiert.
Oder zumindest
konnte ich mich hinauskämpfen.
Darum glaube ich schon,
dass ich sehr behütet wurde.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Obwohl sie seit ihrem Coming-out
nicht mehr auf der Bühne singen darf,
besucht Jasmin mit ihrer Freundin
noch immer die Gottesdienste von ICF.
Für mich ist das einfach ein Ort,
an dem ich ankommen
und herunterfahren kann.
Es gibt mir Frieden
oder ein Gefühl der Erfüllung.
Wir dürfen Sam und Jasmin
nicht in den Saal begleiten -
wegen Corona, heisst es.
# This is our fight, my battle.
Wie?
Bleibt in mir,
und ich bleibe am Tisch bei euch.
Ein Sprecher will uns aber
während des Gottesdienstes sagen,
wie ICF zur Homosexualität steht.
... durch die Reihen gehst.
Ich bete auch für die online.
Livestreaming für alle Locations,
für alle Podcasts, YouTube,
für jeden einzelnen TV-Kanal.
Wir stehen ganz klar
für die Ehe zwischen Mann und Frau.
Das wissen die Menschen,
und dazu stehen wir auch.
Wenn man in unsere Kirche kommt,
gibt es vielleicht eine Spannung
mit dem eigenen Leben.
Trotzdem ist jede Person willkommen.
Unser Wunsch ist, eine Stimme
in der Gesellschaft sein zu können,
die sich für gesunde Ehen
zwischen Mann und Frau ausspricht,
in denen man begeistert ist,
einander liebt
und bis ans Lebensende treu ist.
# Jesus forever,
our praise to the saviour.
Warum aber sind Queers
auf der Bühne nicht willkommen?
Bei ICF darf jede Person mitarbeiten
und sich aktiv
in einem Team eingeben.
Diejenigen, die bei uns
auf der Bühne singen oder sprechen,
sind eigentlich Leiter.
Leiterschaft hat damit zu tun,
dass man dem Bibelverständnis
des ICF zustimmt.
Das ist auch ein Weg -
wir sagen nicht abschliessend,
dass wir alles erkannt haben.
Aber wir erwarten von Leitern,
dass sie hinter unserem biblischen
Verständnis von Sexualität stehen
und das mit ihrem persönlichen
Lebensstil verkörpern können.
Darum hat Jasmin
von sich aus aufgehört, zu singen.
Sie kam auf uns zu
und suchte das Gespräch.
Das haben wir sehr geschätzt,
denn es geht darum,
dass man zu dem steht,
was man auf der Bühne vertritt.
Bei Greenpeace
fährt auch niemand einen SUV.
Es geht um Authentizität,
um Integrität.
Darum ist uns wichtig,
dass diejenigen auf der Bühne
hinter den Dingen stehen,
die wir vertreten.
Ah.
Jede einzelne Eigenschaft ...
Gott hat im Angesicht meines Feindes
den Tisch gedeckt,
und er überfliesst.
Und er salbt mein Haupt mit Öl.
Wenn ich nicht selbst gegangen wäre,
wäre ich rausgeschmissen worden.
Dann hätten sie das Gespräch gesucht
und gesagt,
ich dürfe das nicht mehr tun.
Dadurch versuchen sie ...
Es kommt so rüber, als würden sie
sich so in Schutz nehmen.
Ich finde einfach schlimm,
dass das, was wir leben,
in einer Kirche immer noch
als ungesund bezeichnet wird.
Das entnehme ich zumindest
dieser Aussage.
Der Begriff "gesunde Ehe" ...
Was spricht denn dagegen,
dass wir eine gesunde Beziehung
führen können,
dass wir auch eine
"normale" Beziehung haben können?
Mit diesem Begriff
wird unterstrichen,
dass das nicht möglich ist,
weil es ungesund sei.
Es klingt,
als würde uns das vergiften.
Warum lasst ihr euch das gefallen?
Das hat für mich
verschiedene Gründe.
Zum einen
will ich den Glauben nicht aufgeben,
zum anderen ist es auch wichtig,
denjenigen, die zweifeln,
zu zeigen,
dass auch beides zusammen geht.
Beides zusammen ist in Ordnung.
Wenn ich mich jetzt
in ein Schneckenhaus verziehen
und nicht mehr
zur Kirche gehen würde,
würde ich auch nicht hier sitzen
und darüber reden.
Irgendwann werde ich
die Kirche wahrscheinlich wechseln,
einfach für mich, damit ich nicht
immer diese Menschen sehen muss,
diese Abneigung von Menschen,
die mir etwas bedeutet haben
oder mit denen ich mich mal
megagut verstanden habe.
Das verletzt ja trotzdem
jeden Sonntag wieder aufs Neue.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Liva Tresch und Corinne Rufli -
aus der Forschungsarbeit ...
Geht's, Liva?
- ... ist Freundschaft entstanden.
Es gibt nichts, was ...
... gratis ist.
Das Brett.- Es ist nicht lustig,
in diesem Körper zu sein.
Ich war für die anderen da,
und im Alter
hat sich das Blatt gewendet.
Jetzt liebe ich mich selbst.
Jetzt tut der Verlust
nicht mehr weh.
Jetzt, wo ich mich endlich selbst
respektiere - das klingt so blöd -,
respektieren mich auch die anderen.
Ich kann mich nicht vermehren.
Ich kann keine Kinder machen.
Ich kann den Menschen und dieser
Welt in diesem Sinne nichts geben.
Aber ich kann mein Herz öffnen
und ganz sauber sein,
was ich bin -
nicht mehr und nicht weniger.
Diese Offenheit
ist mein Geschenk an die Menschen.
Wenn sie damit etwas anfangen
können, ist das wunderbar.
Und wenn nicht, ist das ihr Problem.
Dann sind sie noch nicht reif
für diese Sicht.
* Gefühlvolle Klaviermusik *
Wenn ich mich in Drag schminke ...
... passiert etwas.
Der echte Pascal geht weg
und Jeanne kommt.
Wenn ich in Drag bin, fühle ich mich
wunderschön und unantastbar.
Ich fühle mich so, wie sich alle
in ihren kühnsten Träumen fühlen.
Aber die sieben Jahre,
die ich nicht geoutet war
und quasi in einer Welt der komp-
letten Selbstunterdrückung lebte,
haben schon damit zu tun,
dass ich jetzt umso mehr
und umso stärker geniesse,
einfach tun zu können,
worauf ich gerade Bock habe.
Voilà.
Mit Prügeln und Beschimpfungen
wollten sie erreichen,
dass ich mich dafür schäme.
Oder dass ich plötzlich versuche,
hetero zu sein.
Sie glaubten, wenn sie mich
transsexuelle Schwuchtel nennen,
führe das dazu,
dass ich mich schäme.
Das ist sicher nicht passiert.
Ich bin eine transsexuelle
Schwuchtel und stolz darauf.
Wenn schon, bin ich dadurch jetzt
noch stolzer darauf, queer zu sein.
Einfach auch, weil ich gerade
nach dem Überfall gemerkt habe,
wie gut die Community ist ...
... und wie gross der Zusammenhalt
ist. Das hat mir sehr geholfen.
Ich bin auch sehr stolz darauf,
teil der Community sein zu dürfen.
* Leise Stimmen *
Lenny: 150 %.
# He isn't wanted, he isn't loved,
# but he's got to live with it
somehow.
# In both shame and disgust
he gets more hits than he gets hugs.
# Than he gets hugs.
Manchmal frage ich mich heute noch,
wo dieser lustige Vinci ist,
der aus dem Haus gekommen ist
und fand: "Da bin ich."
Der ist manchmal halt nicht mehr
da - auch aus Erschöpfung.
Aus Erschöpfung,
weil es einfach immer noch so ist,
wie es immer gewesen ist.
# The scared little boy
is still inside.
# He fights for his life.
# The scared little boy
is still inside.
# When they come and grab him
# and slip upon him
while he can't move.
# They kick and beat him
and then they ...
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es gewesen wäre,
wenn das mit dir
nicht gewesen wäre -
ob ich jetzt anders denken würde.
Eigentlich braucht jede Gruppe einen
sehr guten Freund, der schwul ist.
(Gamsat)
Mit dem kann man darüber reden.
Er kann einem die Augen
für diese Welt öffnen.
Dann versteht man das auch anders.
# It's a slow burn.
# Oh-o.
Ja, Lenny, das sieht sehr gut aus.
Richtig Power.
Ja, super, genau so.
Gerade rein, gerade raus.
Richtig Power geben. Super.
Ja, sehr schön.
Merkst du, wie viel Kraft du hast?
- Ja.
Cool, was?
Sehr schön. Mach genau so weiter.
Du machst das super.
# I feel like I could float
if you'd attend
# like a nice, united space.
# It's endless and lonely,
# nobody's out here,
somebody please hold me.
# Won't somebody hold me?
* Raketengeräusche *
# Going through life without ...
Wir mussten
so viele Hürden überwinden -
und der Prozess
dauert schon ewig.
Das hat mich
zu einer Kämpferin gemacht.
# ... consume my eyes.
# When they come grab me
and slip upon me
# while I can't move.
# They kick and beat me
and then they leave me there ...
(Jasmin) Es wäre ein Traum, auf der
Bühne einer Kirche singen zu dürfen,
die das akzeptiert
und auch dahinterstehen kann,
dass ich auf der Bühne stehe
und singe,
obwohl ich
mit einer Frau zusammen lebe.
# It's a slow burn,
it's a slow burn.
Hallo.
Hoi.
Aber wirklich nur ein Schlückchen.
# Oh-o.
Wir haben wettpinkeln gemacht,
mit einem langen Schuhlöffel.
Wir haben geschaut, wer am weitesten
in die Limmat hinaus pinkeln konnte.
Einfach so ...
* Sie knurrt. *
* Eindringlicher Poprock *
Wuuu!
- Wu!
# I'm ashamed, I'm paralysed.
(Frau) Yeah!
* Jubel *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2021